[Music]
let's talk about what a great week it's
been for Madonna let's think about this
she was twerking up a storm with James
Corden during carpool karaoke she made a
spectacle in Florida flirting with her
ex Sean Penn and we were there as
Madonna received a big honor do you have
fun oh my guy so much fun it was crazy
it was wild my body was hanging out that
window
Madonna's vehicle bulb went viral with
over three million views in almost 48
hours and today Billboard magazine
celebrated her legacy
congratulations woman of the year it is
an honor obviously it's great to to come
here and to receive this award but more
importantly to speak about women in
music and women in general in the world
today very important time the magazine
honoring the seven-time Grammy winner
for her spectacular three decades plus
career which includes a record of over
1.3 billion dollars earned from concerts
including her recent rebel heart tour
now a documentary which premieres
tonight on Showtime
the 58 year old has made a career out of
shocking audiences last week in Miami
she raised eyebrows at a charity auction
when she told ex-husband Sean Penn she's
still in love with him many moments it
were our marriage and I'm still in love
with you you said that you would marry
Sean again for $150,000 bed rich you
I never say that no no no no he won't he
bought the dress for $150,000 that's a
long story we'll talk about that later
[Music]
you